sensor i just saw mentioned in chat we  just said fabio resign but he actually  made five more moves in that game and  ended up three pieces down so maybe we  can show how the game finished  oh well i mean yeah it was  it was so completely lost that yeah  after rg7 yeah instead of resigning he  continued playing for a bit he played  rookie one and yeah google i'm pretty  sure just calculated everything here  played bishop h3 bishop d6 is i think  the reason favi didn't resign on the  previous move because it looks like it  maybe creates some kind of a mess but  quicker just very calmly accepts the  sacrifice goes king h7 here and yeah the  final blow is 94. thank you very much i  will take that as well  yes thank you thank you for more pieces  and yeah